that's 40 days it's 40 chickens but you
got a whole day to eat the chicken are
you being barred right now because
Bart's not here yeah dude stop being a
bark I just don't know like normal Joe
would be like this guy's tired this is
so cool and then Barbie be like I don't
think this is tight
someone's gotta do it I was like that's
lame he's like what a [__] idiot
[Music]
uh so there's a man you know sometimes
we so there's a man
sometimes we hear stories
um amazing Herculean efforts whether
it's in sports or in life are we talking
about alpha males and goals
perhaps I want I want to know about
Alpha there was a man who felt the
calling though a calling deep down
inside and this calling was to eat 40
rotisserie chickens in 40 days that is a
alpha male big news about this guy it
was big news thought it was the right
thing to do he felt a calling from a
higher power and he answered the [__]
call was it Costco rotisserie chickens
because that can get expensive it is not
Costco rotisserie chicken we talk about
that can be expensive he's like six
bucks a day if he doesn't do the Costco
rotisserie chickens
because the whole chicken yeah you just
phrased it completely wrong but yeah
[Laughter]
missed out the main part yeah yeah don't
cut that out don't cut that out yeah
artists didn't it like on his 40th one
it was like an event yeah like everyone
like came to see him eat the 40s
everybody in town so his name is
Alexander tominski aka the Philadelphia
Chicken Man the Philadelphia chocolate
40 rotisseries he says that doing this
has left him traumatized wow then why'd
he do it well there's a lot to this okay
so he he said there was something in his
subconscious that was pushing him to the
longevity of at least seven days and
then 30 days and then 30 days of eating
rotisserie chickens and then for him he
just he didn't feel enough pain yet
so he took it to 40 rotisserie chickens
wow in 40 days a true patriot yeah yeah
I mean he like whole he's a good dude
yeah he's like holy he's like palming it
yeah eating like an apple yeah it's nice
he's not eating the bones but he's
eating the [__] chicken he's cleaning
the bones oh yeah um and so he's saying
that it's almost like a spiritual thing
right eating rotisserie chicken it's
almost like a sensory overload the smell
the way it sounds when you pull it apart
the taste everything every bit is it's a
very Amplified experience when it comes
to your senses
and the final moments of his mission of
his 40-day uh voyage
we're downright euphoric
he polished off the 40th bird on Sunday
in front of a group of Arden fans who
all came out
um this sounds like again like a Steve
Green made up improv article it's not
this is all made they brought their own
chickens they did not they did it to the
tune of Bruce Springsteen's Streets of
Philadelphia take it away Ryan I don't
know why that song sounds take it away
Ryan you got this ramp
the Streets of Philadelphia
cops exactly like it that's that's
incredible who knew we had a guy who
could do Springs Center oh good for
Springsteen do you guys really know that
song
obviously not it just sounds like it
sounds like that why is this an
accomplishment because you can eat a
rotisserie chicken you really asking one
you could take
this okay Joe come on man 40 days are
you gonna shame his goal but like you
gotta it's 40 days it's 40 chickens but
you got a whole day to eat the chicken
are you being bought right now because
Bart's not here yeah dude stop being a
bark I just don't know like 40 40
chickens in 40 days is the sound of a
good movie
normal Joe would be like this guy's
tired this is so cool and then Barbie
like I don't think this is tight
someone's got to do it I was like that's
lame yeah he's like that'll get it yeah
he's like what a [__] idiot that's
what he would say only because
I feel like a little bit kind of jealous
and hurt because when I was gaining
weight I had to eat a Costco chicken one
whole chicken a day I don't really care
at home so that's why I look at this and
I go is it that badass because I did
that whole chicken plus some every day
dude how do you do it because those are
fatty ass chickens they're the Costco
chickens I could do a whole rotation in
one whole day yeah yeah but I could only
do it once I'm not gonna do it tomorrow
it's morning lunch in the night time
yeah it definitely starts to taste like
nothing yeah especially the white meat
Parts too you're just like it tastes
like nothing from the jump I think this
is this is how you do it okay it's
Phantom chicken good you get that I love
it no the Costco one is not good for
some reason yeah I mean it's tasteless
so you get the wings you get the thigh
and the leg you separate that for your
like other Meals by itself the white
meat you pull it all apart make soup
with it exactly and that's how I cleared
that every day soup well that's what I
can see why it's hard for you because
you're a hot sauce boy you're not gonna
eat no Bland regular rotisserie oh do I
I covered in Tabasco sauce I don't even
sweater I do try powerful you guys
remember the rotisserie gold at KFC
that's just like what Legends were made
of like they don't you just they came
out just for a brief time it was so good
it was actually good well I was a child
so everything salty was good and you
said it was KFC KFC it was called the
rotisserie gold and my one of my closest
friends his name was Roy and that was
that he introduced it to me so we called
him Roy tisserie gold that's funny and
and you know it's chock full of [__]
MSG so you know it's gonna it's
guaranteed to be good do you think that
he hates his nickname because he has to
explain it and everyone he goes into now
he's like hey I'm rotisserie Roy test
for gold and then everyone's like what
the [__] is that so in the 90s there was
this like you know we didn't know it
would go away hey Roy tisserie if you're
out there DM me because I I use some
chicken yeah Roy cheswigo we were
cracking up dying like my nickname is
really hard it's hard on me that sucks
to be named after something you think
has staying power but it's just like why
do they call you Arch Deluxe they call
me crystal Pepsi
Crystal peps I feel like everyone in the
90s had a fat friend that was named
after food
I didn't live in the same 90s movies you
did my friends
who was your friend from the 90s history
yeah he was back in and he loved Fried
Chicken
did you get it when you were a fat kid
did anyone give you a name based on food
like all food oh no let's bring it back
to trauma yeah
dude it was a long time ago okay dude
it's fine you're all hot now what was my
favorite food at the time when I was
super fat yeah
probably data snacks
beta snacks
hey watch out for your lungs man we want
you to like last it's a whooping cough
you know I think those names came up
because they would see the kid with this
same thing over and over oh yeah like
they're always eating this thing
you know like hamburgers or something
because you made fun of each other's
lunches as kids too yeah oh when I was
fat uh Hot Cheetos and nacho cheese
that's that's dip the Cheetos and the
cheese how fat were you not that fat but
everybody just likes to like talk about
me in a really special way but it's kind
of comforting well he was also shorter
so then you know oh cool betta food yeah
you blew it up you [__] piece of [__]
intercepted
I already knew you're gonna do that he
flew he blew it up that's Anthony's it's
Anthony's favorite snack you like that
you like that food you like that took
away that punchline
that war right here oh you blew every
piece
that's what he ate he loved this snack
it used to be memes it used to be for
[__] kicks and for the walls now time
bro you brought you brought the war home
so no this guy this guy's basically
saying that um
he absorbs he absorbs the the [__]
lives of the chicken and The Vibes of
the chicken he like why is he over
explaining it so much
so the chicken is stressed yeah Steve
this is like the worst story
I think he lacks meaning in his life I
think he [__] doesn't know you know
who lacks meaning the [__] fans that
went to go watch him eat the chicken
those are the guys like me anymore in
this [__] guy at least he did
something pretty cool yeah he did
something really great
why is this in the newspaper what small
town is this first because that's how
good his branding is like like Ryan said
this is like a big [__] story big
thing dude
where all over no I mean where is he
where is this located dude
that's a huge story I don't know where
it is talk about the eagle Commanders
oh I'm from Philly what a weird
accomplishment especially
I'm from Philly now do Chicago
's like April Fool
that's pretty good that was really good
too accurate it was kind of me a new
soccer
when I went to uh Philly I had to try
Philly cheesecakes and the tourist spot
to go to is Gino's and Pats what'd you
think
I was shocked that people actually speak
the way they do in Philly I thought it
was the movies you know how like people
pretend like California dude talk yeah
no one talks here like that really there
is right but not really so that whole
like Italian like hey what do you want
to put your order you know that kind of
[__] I thought that was like
just jokes
like I thought that was a character do
you think they put it on a little
because they know tourists are coming
maybe maybe they're like as soon as they
leave yeah
like grab some beers tonight or what
made some good sales today didn't we
because
it's not like I was hoping it would
sound like that it was when I was there
they have well it doesn't quite Sound
New York but it's that same kind of
thing and I was like I do New York do
New York they're walking here yeah
that's it New York do New York Hawaii
I'm walking here you call this Porky
that's my favorite [__] you call this
[__] Porky my mother makes better pokies
nah you could have you could have ended
it so much sooner than this but you
wanted us to suffer
[Music]
thank you